pour ces portugais il fallait savoir se
montrer patient ce dimanche dès la
matinée devant cette université de
lisbonne
de longues files d'attentes se sont
formées on voit qu'il ya beaucoup de
personnes qui sont venues voter c'est
toujours bon de voir l'exercice de la
citoyenneté dans le vote c'est très
important je pensais qu'il y aurait
moins de gens aujourd'hui que dimanche
prochain
mais finalement j'ai l'impression que
c'est le contraire il y a une bonne
participation et j'en déduis que pour
beaucoup c'est important que le pays est
un bon président à contexte
exceptionnelle décision exceptionnelle
après avoir enregistré des chiffres
records de contamination et de décès
liés au co vide au cours de la semaine
le pays a dû s'adapter malgré l'entrée
en vigueur d'un deuxième confinement
vendredi le premier ministre antonio
costa donc décidé de maintenir
l'élection présidentielle du 24 janvier
et d'organiser en amont ce scrutin
anticipé une idée bien accueillie par
les électeurs ce vote c'est d'abord une
question de logistique afin d'éviter les
grandes foules le jour même de
l'élection et c'était important d'avoir
la garantie que nous puissions voter
cette fois ci selon les chiffres du
ministère de l'intérieur près de deux
cent quarante sept mille électeurs
s'étaient inscrits pour prendre part à
ce vote par anticipation un chiffre très
largement supérieur aux cinquante six
mille votants des dernières législatives
de 2010 9
cette élection présidentielle ne
sembleraient donc pas forcément pâtir
d'une campagne réduite à son strict
minimum du fait des restrictions
sanitaires au portugal l'élection du
président de la république se fait au
suffrage universel et pour un mandat de
cinq ans renouvelable une fois
sur les sept candidats en lice c'est le
président conservateur marcelo rebelo de
souza qui est donné gagnant par les
sondages dès le premier tour